wenn ich Vorträge halte oder bei
Veranstaltungen wie der IdeenExpo auf
der Bühne stehe dann merke ich immer
wieder nur live ist wirklich
live wenn ich da etwas erkläre und die
Leute verstehen das dann sieht man das
in den Gesichtern da geht wirklich ein
Licht auf und deswegen will ich schon
seit langer Zeit mal die Location
wechseln raus aus dem Youtube Studio und
rauf auf die Bühne und genau dieser
Traum wird jetzt endlich warm wir haben
uns angeschaut wo die meisten dr Watson
Zuschauer sind und die Städte danach
ausgewählt es geht darum wie wir in der
Zukunft leben werden wie werden wir uns
im Jahr 2050 fortbewegen wie werden wir
uns ernähren werden wir auf dem Maß
Leben all das und noch viel mehr werde
ich beantworten live aus der Zukunft
holt euch jetzt Tickets unter
drwatson.shop